it's going around with these dummies
wait here what do you teach Comparative
historiography of the French and
American revolutions nope how about you
molecular biology worse what do you
study abnormal psychology so like
weirdos and freaks you should meet my
friend
hey do you know what are you thinking
about right now I was thinking how I
would make the perfect American
president based upon my skill set dance
ability and bloodlust that is
fascinating
Ashanti hey show these garbage people
out take the garbage out Eddie
Donna gentlemen
no signs of forced entry at the door but
the window was Jimmy your locks on your
windows way to blame the victim sorry
I'm not rich like you miss 1% they cost
$8 you have a fur bedspread why do you
have so many lycra bodysuits and why do
you need eight full drawers of underwear
because I'm civilized
less talky talk more soggy salt we need
an itemized list of everything that was
stolen I already gave it to captain Holt
160 dollars in cash one TV one large
painting of a naked lady on a lion one
set of Joseph gordon-levitt nesting
dolls homemade and irreplaceable one
music box that plays she works hard for
the money when opened one knock-off
designer clutch she's just buying on a
knockoff no I can't silly soo cuz the
label no longer makes the original so
the sweatshop no longer makes the
knockoff can you estimate the value of
everything that was taken emotionally
seven hundred million dollars is blood
Lake now I missed the first three death
canoe films why exactly is it a defconn
it is a tip over easily read my Twitter
feed I live-tweeted the first three this
morning in preparation in the fifth one
the canoes actually the hero
it's crazy twists son I'm just saying
you should have put spoiler alert on all
those death canoe tweets also
not-safe-for-work
you know a lot of what you wrote was
really profane the movie is 25 years old
Morris and if you don't like how I tweet
don't follow me
what are you doing now I'm talking to
you I'm live tweeting this dumbass
conversation okay this is the Junior
police program
aka Mission Possible
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to get your life back on track
[Music]
I have nothing to offer since I'm not a
cop I thought I'd just show up and learn
you want to help me out here no I think
I'm good I know you think getting in
trouble is cool but let me show you what
can happen if you continue down this
path hey yo I'm an at-risk kid and I
think it's cool to sell drugs huh why
does the kids on drugs sound like he's
black he's not well why not are you
saying that black people can't sell
drugs no I'm not saying that we have a
black president why can't black people
sell drugs
I'm so confused black people can sell
drugs
Whitey's choice Oh wildcard option okay
anybody reveal anything about their life
anything at all I've gotten to
annulments one for pleasure and one to
cap off a long con I was running against
Keith Sweat Wow let's talk about
personal relationships who wants to
start Donna I have several men of
rotation ones waiting for me out in the
car window hey beardo it's time for you
to get out of Charles's house today hang
on man you don't tell me what to do uh
that's where you're wrong baby girl I
run this precinct watch this Scully
go to sleep okay you think you can
intimidate me yeah when I was undercover
Jimmy the butcher cut off my little toe
with garden shears and made me eat it as
a loyalty test I've been through hell
big deal
I worked at a sunglass kiosk at the mall
for four years so not only have I been
through hell I was assistant manager
there yeah you're gonna get out of
Chuckies house and once more you're
gonna pay him rent for the night you
spent there
fine one more thing babe you're gonna
thank us both right now thank you you're
welcome thank you you're welcome
that was amazing told you he just need
it to be outfit is that what happened or
did I just beta you into protecting me
no no it's not what happened
this is not your victory sure oh my god
I was shot in the head with a shotgun
well it's actually not that serious I
just need you to stay calm okay yeah I'm
just gonna stay angry I find that
relaxes me okay Romi call 9-1-1 and
they're gonna send a ranger oh damn
this is a mess the Rangers won't let us
come back next year what we're not gonna
think about that right now you guys can
you just put him on the daybed in the
car okay
what is it your heart
you can't run that space heater 24/7 a
space heater excuse me this is a foreign
accent comfort system and her name is
Jacinta okay well just sentence got to
go he didn't mean that darling seriously
turn off the space eater no do it now
that's an order yeah well you don't want
to start a battle of the Wills with Gina
linetti because you will emerge from
that battle a broken man not to brag but
I was named checked in my kindergarten
teachers suicide note hi I'm Anne Brian
what's your occupation I'm a manager at
a sporting goods store no way me too
seriously which one no I'm not and I I
was just ribbing here what are you
drinking yeah what oh I don't know I I
couldn't hear you
so you just laughed and said yeah yeah
excuse us
that was the worst thing I've ever seen
in my life did you up in the woods or
you know from the movie milk I told you
I'm rusty
alright come at me you always want to
scribble the name make them read draw
them in make them work for it
great two shots of Jameson don't make
too much eye contact you want to see
them available but not two of it Thanks
I think I'm good for now I'm not gonna
yeah all right let's do this and I
figured PR would be the easiest path to
launching my reality show
Leonetti set go I thought your reality
show was to be called Gina in a bottle
no that was my fragrance line keep up
listen you cannot let lunch defeat you
that is not who you are you are a person
who will go out there and deliver his
eight-point plan on whatever whatever we
may be engagement whatever even if the
only people listening are a bunch of
second graders because captain Raymond
Holt never gives up that's very words
I'm going to give that speech help me
with that pigeon head
let's blow some tiny minds hey whatever
happened to you and the bionic man Chris
he broke up with me but he did it so
nicely that I didn't even realize he did
it I've done that to multiple men how
you doing you don't okay thank you so
much for asking it's been tough
yeah two days ago I was sobbing at a
pizza buffet and they asked me to leave
I've been looking at some dog adoption
websites about $700 with the candles
from Anthropologie I did this to my hair
you know your basic bottoming out kind
of stuff yeah normally people tell you
to talk about your problems I'm gonna
recommend you follow that noise up
that's what my mailman said hmm ya feel
Oh what are you doing tonight I think
I'm gonna have to pass your loss are you
gonna get that him he's an exactly
boyfriend material who said anything
about a boyfriend use him abuse him lose
him I shot Ron Swanson
you